here I just want to make a short video
to announce that I'm gonna be in Berlin
on October the 24th evening I arrived
24th 25th 26th evening and then 27th
hour to fly back to Vancouver I know I'm
going to be there on the 25th and 26th
to take part in the parkin the hoof
trade show language learning in the
corporate sector and also briefly to
visit the Expo lingua but I also want to
try to organize a meet up on the evening
of the 26th with any linkers or language
Keener's or people in Berlin who would
like to meet up with other people who
are interested in languages so we
haven't yet decided on the venue it'll
be I think 7 o'clock at night on the
26th in Berlin and one suggestion which
and I'm gonna leave a link for it here
is the rest of hats on to hold ski which
is a restaurant that was recommended
I'll put a link so you can have a look
please let us know let me know here if
you I would like to join us it would be
great to meet up with language Keener's
such as we did in Prague and have done
it elsewhere in the dread Florence and
Melbourne and Sydney and so forth so
meet up in Berlin October 26 in the
evening at 7:00 right now the suggested
venue is this hostel Hudson to hold ski
but we are open to other suggestions
first of all let's find out how many of
you are gonna be joining us there are of
link a great contributor to our German
library and her daughter are gonna be
there and a few others as well so please
let me know meet up in Berlin October
26th thanks for listening bye for now